I had Judd's assistant or somebody's
email from when he did the penome show
six months earlier
and I emailed Josh Church an email Josh
church and I go hey Josh uh I have an
idea for Judd
um does he have 15 minutes for me and
they're they're like yeah but we're in
New York shooting Trainwreck
I wish I had more stories like this
because this is such a fun story
yeah but I'm doing all of this almost in
a fit of mania like I am today on manic
today but not not many bipolar I just
mean I'm very flared outside yeah so I'm
emailing Josh and he's like he can see
you Friday morning uh we're on like 26th
and 10th or something they're they're in
New York wow the fact that he made time
for you so soon yes but they didn't I
don't think he knew that I was in LA and
I was just like I'll see you there you
got on a plane I flew out the next day I
didn't even have to pitch
oh I left out the key part before I
emailed I thought
okay what's interesting about me I'm a
raise religious and I'm divorced that's
fine you you tell me you have a show you
want to do about that I'm like okay
you're 70 of the way there and then I
went and when my wife leaves me I have
nowhere to stay but I stay with a
different comedian every episode and I
go now we have what's called an engine
there's there's a repeatable pattern
whether or not you do that that's how
you sell a pilot because you plant in
the executive's mind oh I can see how
this is something with legs right right
so once I had that epiphany of like [ __ ]
and we call it crashing right literally
like writing it on the airline napkin
real cliche wow flew to the center not
even knowing what you're going to talk
about and coming up with it on the way
on the flight yeah writing it out I wish
I had that napkin I get to the set of
train wreck they're shooting in the
magazine office Vanessa Bayer is there
um the kid who plays The Flash is there
um and Amy is there of course and I know
Amy a little bit so I'm talking with Amy
and then at some point they call cut and
they take a break and I get 10 I think
it was 10 12 minutes to pitch uh
crashing and I wasn't I'm better at
pitching now but I wasn't really good at
it but luckily Judd liked it he was
getting into stand-up at the time like
getting back into doing it so pitching a
stand-up origin story to a guy who's
going through his second stand-up origin
story and also frankly knowing what I
know now Judd wanted to be with
comedians he wanted to be doing sets he
wanted to do a comedy tour to promote
all this stuff so it was right were you
nervous when you when you were pitching
him yeah I didn't I let's say the
meeting I think I met him at like seven
I was probably about five did he say
let's get on with it right away like no
Small Talk was there any small talker
the whole thing was small talk they're
never was like a okay so imagine a
little show called crashing but it
wasn't like but at this point your wife
hadn't divorced you yet you you weren't
cheated on yet oh no no no this is this
is years after that oh years after that
so the whole cheating thing this is many
years after I got divorced when I was
28. and at this point I am 30
for four were you absolutely depressed
and just crushed when that happened I
love that you're steering it back to a
more relatable area for you yeah were
you lonely were you lonely
I need somebody to relate to me I would
love to relate to you that's the story
but I can can I say one more thing to
that no please I love this go the best
part is to me is Judd didn't say yes you
know what he said he said write 15 pages
a purge it felt like a challenge I'm an
Enneagram why my wing is four I don't
know if you know what that is I kind of
kind we love our own pain okay three is
the achiever that's my main number but I
have a four Wing which means I love
Radiohead you know what I mean like I I
love sad stuff the national is my
favorite band I love the Nationals
wouldn't you really do the podcast I I
when I was like asking you I was like
who's easy who's like a friend he's easy
Matt is it my friend and Mark duplos is
easy and Mark duplex but he won't be
back in town until uh I have a note yes
I I believe I love Mark did you see what
creep the creep movies oh my God they're
so good okay you can watch it I [ __ ]
love it okay go so go back so he right
he goes it's a challenge he goes write
15 pages of or maybe it's 10 but he was
like just write everything you remember
about being divorced and I was writing
about losing my erection while I was
masturbating like you ever been so sad
that you can't jerk off course but that
was sleep jerking off yeah that's a
little different yeah that's a different
kind of giving up this was like I don't
even want me you know what I mean like
you can't even but you I really sidebar
you really realize when I got divorced
there was even a part of me because I
liked jerking off so much I was like oh
I can just jerk off all the time like
what's I had never really been single
right uh and it turns out sex and
drinking off her completely different
things you know like you need a like you
want a body you want as Jackie Novak
Jacqueline Novak says you want the hug
of it you know right jerking off is just
released yeah but I was like I'll just
do this and I was like after a while I
was like you're pushing it's like the
engine on the Enterprise you're really
pushing the limits of how much you can
self-soothe this way right but I put all
the most embarrassing stuff in there
that I could muster my mom kisses me on
the lips all that sort of stuff and I
think I so I met him and I sent it to
him like the next day and then I also he
was telling me stand-up premises and I
also sent them in the car to the airport
the next morning I just rode out tags
and like just like kind of manically
being like hey you know that baby
pitched me here's like and he wrote back
I'll never forget he wrote back this is
the nicest thing anyone's ever done for
me I was like okay I think we're
becoming friends and then he's when he
read the pilot I wrote a pilot
after the document and I rewrote that
pilot I think six or seven times with
different people so not just a rewrite
but like what if it was Hannibal what if
it was Amy Schumer what if it was you
know all none of them were already it
ended up being already laying but that I
wrote it and I was so young and hungry
and didn't have a baby to be honest I I
would trade my baby for all of this but
like when you don't have a baby I can
write a script in a couple days and now
it's it's a little bit harder but anyway
there was all of this Mr miyagiang and
you didn't instill it wasn't a yes we're
doing this it still wasn't a yes right
but he was asking and I was doing and it
was real it was also mixing metaphors it
was very like uh Charles Sims incentive
woman and he was Frank Slade uh Slade
slate uh he was Pacino right
people who know me know I'm tempted to
do my Pacino but
anyway that that's that's the story of
of crashing more or less wow yeah
foreign